[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
it's a comedy podcast about death where
myself and my friend Tyler Oakley this
week give you dubious advice answer your
questions and bring you all the week's
news from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon
hank is away on leave so I am joined by
Tyler Oakley how are you Tyler I'm good
thank you so much for having me thank
God Hank is gone I know finally I get to
live my dream of Dear John and Tyler you
are of course you know what I think the
people have been waiting for everyone's
eager to hear no I'm sorry to be here
thank you
um talk about your own podcast a little
bit do a little self promo that's kind
of your specialty sure so my best friend
Korey Kuhl and I have a podcast together
we've been doing it for two years now
it's called psychobabble it's stories
we've never told pop culture commentary
advice and everything in between it's
literally whatever we want to talk about
every single Tuesday and yeah it's a lot
of fun I really love your podcast and I
have to say I love your best friend
Korey he's an amazing amazing person
he's okay he's he I haven't killed him
yet
we just got matching tattoos together so
I guess we're bonded for life so oh my
gosh really what are the tattoos um it's
a outline of two hands doing like a
pinky promise oh that's super cool see
you think it's tender but at the end of
the day it's really just us usually what
we do drunk at a bar we're promising
each other that we'll get Taco Bell
afterward the really girls tender but
not the really great matching tattoo is
when you get the word Taco tattooed on
yourself and he gets the word Bell
tattooed on himself so you're never
complete until you're together I mean a
taco is pretty complete without the Bell
a bell without the taco is just kind of
sad that's actually a really good point
yeah no that's a terrible bit Tyler I'm
gonna answer do you have tattoos wait I
need to know do you have tattoos I do
not have any tattoos I have thought
about getting a tattoo many times but I
think that ship
might have sailed I'm 39 you know it's
never too late I love an old person with
a sleeve and by old person I mean you
was I was about to point out that I'm
not an old person but I suppose that I
am aren't you like in your mid to late
20s at this point I'm just 18 no we had
a conversation recently sorry I know you
want to do like advice and things and
questions but we didn't we just have a
conversation about how we're both old on
YouTube now so I think we're we're
qualified to give advice and answer
questions yeah I agree we are a little
bit where YouTube old you're not old
really by any definition except by
YouTube definitions of age I am old by
most definitions all right Tyler I'm
gonna get to a question because I think
this is a very important first question
okay are you ready yes I've never been
more this question comes from Hannah who
writes dear Hank and John I was catching
up with a friend in a cafe the other day
when she offered me some of her trail
mix she put it on the table in the
middle and then we went back to talking
my question is this how much of another
person's food slash snack am I allowed
to consume before it is deemed
inappropriate can I keep reaching back
for more should I only eat the first
bite that I grab why do I act sneakily
when I try to eat this snack that they
have generously offered me to eat oh my
god
have you ever been in that situation
I've been in that situation a lot where
someone will say like you want some
Doritos and I'll be like yeah and then
I'll just take the bag of Doritos and
I'll eat all of it and then they'll look
at me weird but like why did you say do
you want some Doritos here's the thing I
think you have to read their social cues
if they're chowing down and they offer
you some you I think you can match their
pace but not exceed it also if it's
trail mix you can't just take the best
thing in right you can't just take the
M&Ms right you can't just take the M&Ms
you can't just take the like the brown
chips in the Chex Mix you know what I
mean like you have to kind of be fair no
I totally agree that's a great point
like of course everybody has a bag of
trail mix and then you end up and it's
just like a bunch of raisins and almonds
in the bottom of it at the end of the
day so you got to eat all the trail mix
and you have to follow
apparently something that Tyler calls
social cues I have no idea what those
are well you
we'll dine together sometime soon and
I'll teach you a tacit you just like
walk me through all of it right and I'll
SWAT your hand if you grab something
you're not supposed to I deeply which is
my life motto that's what I do it like
Oh Tyler can I ask you a question that
comes from me you can ask me anything
how are you enjoying this election
season it's actually um it feels like
it's eating away at my soul truly yeah
this is a question we've gotten from a
lot of listeners including listeners who
don't live in the United States who are
like why are you doing this to us
which you know fair question it's it's
eating away at my soul a little bit as
well I feel like I am I am very invested
in it and I can't imagine I think there
are certain levels of identity which it
which it probably has hurt more to
witness at all I can't imagine
identifying as a woman and seeing
everything that's happening I can't
imagine being a person of color and
seeing everything that's happening or
being ignored but as a gay man and as a
millennial or whatever I might identify
a millennial it has been it has been
shocking the witness and embarrassing to
accept as our reality yeah it's really
really hard to accept as our reality and
I just hope I keep kind of hoping that
somehow it's going to magically end on
the morning of November 9th and I don't
know if that's going to prove to be true
but it has been this weird very intense
I think largely unprecedented moment in
American history there's never been
political divisive miss like this at
least not in the 20th or 21st century
we've never seen a candidate anything
like Trump calling into question the
legitimacy of the election you know
making statements that undermine the
fundamental political institutions of
the United States I mean putting aside
policy that stuff is to me pretty
terrifying and it's just a reminder this
whole thing has reminded me that
American history is quite short this is
all quite new
and it's all a little fragile you know
totally I mean the amount of people that
can sweep aside or not care about the
unprecedented things that are happening
in this election like somebody saying
that they might not accept the results
like that's a pretty big deal
and that's a huge deal I mean it's it
really is there is no precedent for that
at least not since the Civil War and
that is a huge deal I was just watching
the Hamilton documentary that was on PBS
and there's have you seen first of all
have you seen in Hamilton I have not
seen Hamilton it's a very sad story I
was supposed to see Hamilton in New York
City we had tickets we were in the
airport on our way there and I have this
weird disease called yoson Affiliate
esophagitis this is part of my being old
and sometimes food gets stuck in my
esophagus and steak got stuck in my
esophagus while we were in the airport
on our way to see Hamilton and I had to
go to the hospital and get an emergency
endoscopy and it's it's just the worst
anyway I will see it soon but it is a
I've not seen it but I have listened to
the soundtrack literally 500 times so
you're familiar with one last time the
song about George Washington stepping
away and kind of setting yes and for
two-term system allowing a country to
move on past its first leader yeah and
in the documentary on PBS it kind of
explores a peaceful transition and how
that has become so crucial for a country
and for half of America to seemingly not
care about a peaceful transition is
scary yeah I hope it's not half I mean I
I do hold out some hope that it's not
half and that there's a yeah but it is I
don't I don't want to I also don't want
to undersell how bad it is I'd also want
to be aware of the fact that it's much
worse for like you said earlier it's
much worse for people who aren't me and
like I benefit from a lot of privilege
in this conversation about the election
in general and I'm trying
to be conscious of that but I hope that
it's not half we'll see but yeah it will
see I would love it to be I would love
it to be just a statement so many people
show up to vote that it is a statement
to the world that this is not who we are
like it's one thing for polls to say you
know what they're predicting but people
have to show up and show the world
that's not who we are that's not a great
point so everybody if you can vote do
and if you don't know if you can vote go
to youtube.com slash how to vote in
every state Hank's a magic amazing
project that will tell you how to vote
in every state in the Union and
Washington DC and if you are a citizen
living abroad as well I loved his I
loved his series I think I thought it
was really helpful and plus it was
interesting to see the differences
between different places and how to vote
absentee and all these things I thought
I thought it was really crucial and
necessary so thanks Hank
Thank You Hank you're a good person a
good brother and a good citizen I bet
there's a lot of people that are
underage and can't vote there's still
ways to get involved use your voice on
social media and remind people the day
before text everyone you know like hey
just a reminder tomorrow you vote I
can't I wish I could please exercise
your right because I can't or if you
want to write it give somebody a ride to
their polling station sometimes that's
the difference between if they vote or
not so you can be that difference
absolutely Tyler I want to get to even
more serious questions if you don't mind
this one comes from Stacey who writes
dear Hank and John I was appalled to
learn last week that my husband of over
11 years believes that quesadillas and
tacos are sandwiches clearly they are
not
please help settle this debate so our
house can once again be peaceful and we
can decide how to properly raise our
children longtime fan of the pod
Stacey well that is traumatising yeah
it's upsetting I mean you never want to
discover something like that 11 years
into a marriage that's the kind of thing
that you really Stacey I don't want to
criticize you in the situation but it
seems to me that you guys should have
had that talk before you got married
I mean I have to maybe give him some
credit because nope content within carbs
is a sandwich no content within carbs
is not a sandwich I think the whole
definition was managed there is a word
for a Mexican sandwich it is called a
torta there is it exists it is a thing
in the world I don't know well I think a
hotdog is a sandwich mmm very marginal i
I think this might be our first
disagreement I think I'm on his side I
think it's important to accept by all
shapes and forms of sandwiches and some
of them are yeah you know what no but
panini is a sandwich and a panini is a
is bread but thinner and so if we take
it one step further and go even thinner
would that not be a quesadilla well if
you take it one step further and then
you're just grilling cheese that is also
not a sandwich like you've got to draw
the line for sandwich at some pie don't
know if I have will ever draw that line
I've got to say in my opinion and I
guess the answer here Stacey is that if
Tyler and I are able to maintain our
friendship in the in spite of Tyler's
ridiculous statement that a quesadilla
is somehow a sandwich I think that you
and your husband can probably like
figure it out and make it work and I
have absolute confidence in you but
Tyler is wrong on this one Stacey I
don't think John and I will ever recover
so divorce is an option that's right I
mean you've got to keep all your options
on the table Stacey I'd be a great thing
to tell the kids - so why'd you guys
break up mom and dad Oh your dad
believes that sandwiches and tacos are
the same thing all I'm saying is the
straw that breaks the camel's back that
single straw is not heavy that is not a
straw I'm sorry if that is destroyed
your relationship like you care way too
much about sandwiches listen you you
guys hash it out and you get back to us
yeah let us know if you're able to move
on from this all right let's uh let's
move on to another question dear Hank
and John I know John has had experience
with depression after being broken up
with I was wondering as someone with a
boyfriend who I think is at risk of
having the same issue what is the best
way to break up with someone to help
them of
with that scenario move move my god how
do you break up with someone so that
they that they're not impacted by it
yeah you're not gonna be able to break
up with someone so that they're not
impacted by it but I also as someone
who's been on the other side of that
coin a couple times like looking back I
realized that it is it was not that
person's responsibility and it was not
that person's fault so you know what
happens to your boyfriend after you
break up is not your fault obviously
don't be I mean that would be my take
anyway like don't be cruel but keep firm
boundaries and if you need to end the
relationship you need to end the
relationship you know I think open
communication throughout the
relationship helps a peaceful transition
I think if if you bring up something
that you've never brought up before
while you're breaking up with someone
that's not the easiest way to break the
news so right if you haven't tried to
work through it not saying that you have
to try to work through it but if it's if
it's something out of the blue I think
that's detrimental to their process of
moving on I think also if you commit to
breaking up with someone commit to it
you can't be wishy-washy you can't offer
you know maybe some day in the future we
might get back together like that really
messes with someone in their ability to
move on it's so hard to do that but
you're right I mean this is all good
advice but it's really hard to do I was
recently dumped not recently no in the
grand scheme of my life recently I and
one thing that I was really grateful for
was he he said I just don't see us ever
being I think and like that is then
stung in the minute but how great that I
had no question of maybe someday right
you know what I mean like to to just
have a closure to it even though that
was like probably difficult for him to
say because like that's not a nice
feeling to give to somebody but like
down the line that was helpful for me to
be able to be like okay I it's time for
me to like accept it and move on org
it's yeah no I totally agree like having
those boundaries during a breakup is
really hard but I think it's really
important and in my experience anyway I
haven't been able to move on until I've
accepted that you know I've accepted
that the relationship is over
and also you know accepted that I'm
gonna have a good and fulfilling life
that you know isn't going to involve
having a romantic relationship with this
person right I agree it's hard though I
mean there's no easy way to break up and
but I I think you make a great point
that if in the context of the
relationship the lines of communication
are open the breakups gonna go a lot
smoother and it shouldn't seem so out of
the blue I mean if a breakup is out of
the blue then you're right that's just I
don't think that's the most kosher way
to go about it I totally agree yeah I
mean it that should be part of the lines
of communication in a relationship being
open I've never been surprised by a
breakup which speaks highly of the
people I've dated usually when Hank has
a special guest by the way Tyler like
it's all fun in games like Flula was on
an episode and like you and I are just
we're just diving deep that's okay with
me I am a man of versatility like this
home down this is what I would do every
week I would just go I would just go
straight for the jugular but yeah
there's no easy way to to break up I got
another I got another dating question
for you Tyler comes from Liz I mean all
I can think of all I can think of with
you saying straight for the jugular is
the piece of steak stuck so be careful
easy stick stuck in my esophagus like I
mean I don't want to gross you out but
like the worst part about this when it
happens like the steak getting stuck in
my esophagus is that I can't swallow
water like I can't swallow my own spit
even so I just like puke up my own spit
every 3 or 4 minutes for hours until I
finally get this endoscopy done it was
super annoying you know what for some
people that's a turn
I'm sure so one male's trash I mean I
would do great with a very specific
subset of the population god bless my
esophagitis is acting up I have to say I
have another new problem since then all
right let's answer this question for MU
Liz who writes Dear John and Hank I
recently decided to try online dating
maybe this will get me an opportunity to
tell my awesome online dating stories
from way back in the old person days
more specifically OkCupid one thing I
like about it is that you answer a bunch
of questions and then they do fancy
calculations to determine how much of a
match you are with other users the idea
is that more is better but is it really
a good idea to be with someone who's a
98% match aren't you then too alike on
the other side I feel pretty confident
that I won't hit it off with someone
who's a 50% match but then what should
be my minimum threshold to consider
meeting someone what range of match
percentage is actually the ideal amount
hmm I mean I at one point in my life was
on OkCupid and I found no success I
found it to be accurately named just
okay for me though if you're looking at
percentage like sure you can agree that
you both want a dog sure you can agree
that you both love a cookout but like
right is anything's really going to
accurately detect sense of humor or
personality like right a sense of charm
you feeling butterflies like I don't
know if I could ever boil down a
successful relationship to a handful of
questions let alone 200 questions I
think over the course of a few dates
you'll go through many more than that
and some of those things like are not
deal-breakers so I don't know if OkCupid
you can weight the importance of a
question or if it weights it for you so
I don't even know if I believe in the
system to begin with so I don't know if
I can reckon a percentage that's
accurate or worthwhile to pursue
yeah I'm inclined to agree my feeling
about OkCupid is when I look at my
relationship with my wife you know I
suspect
that we would not have been a match in a
lot of ways that OkCupid considers
important but the things that are really
important to Sarah and me are you know
some of the things you talked about like
charm sense of humor the fact that we
have shared values which is incredibly
important and really difficult for
algorithms to understand like if
algorithms were better at understanding
human values then the whole internet
would work a lot better than it does and
and I think that stuff has to kind of
come out in conversation like no matter
how many interests you share that's a
relatively small part of a relationship
in my experience so Liz we're gonna say
that a zero percent match is fine like
don't don't worry about it too much I I
was really really terrible at internet
dating Tyler back in the gosh the
2002-2003 era when I was on internet
dating it was different than like the
vibe of it was different there was no
Grindr or anything but I did I did meet
people from the internet and went on
dates with them almost always to the
same German restaurant which looking
back maybe wasn't the best call and I
did have a couple of like semi serious
relationships emerge out of those
experiences but oh man it was hard I my
experience with internet or app dating I
have found I just
and maybe this is me personally I just
find that if I meet somebody organically
I feel like we get into a better rhythm
from the start I feel like if you're on
the internet learning everything about
somebody it's it's a curated amount of
what they want to share and who they
want to be perceived as and sometimes
that really messes with it maybe the
accuracy of the match especially in a
system of like sending five pictures and
that's what represents you
mmm I put five pictures that I might
pick for myself might not be the five
pictures my soul my soulmate might think
represent me I mean like right totally
and and when you meet somebody
organically you're seeing them as a
fully fledged human and how their
mannerisms come into play and maybe that
doesn't translate on I don't know in in
the digital space so I take the
presentation of a human on a social
media app or on OkCupid as a grain of
salt I mean it's it's who they want to
be and it's what they think they are
that has no relation to how you would
perceive them in a romantic sense so can
I tell you a story that will make me
seem super crazy old yes does it start
with an okay I mean does it start with a
yahoo chats chat room
Oh Tyler Oh Tyler it occurs long before
Yahoo chats so back in 1992 my dad
brought home CompuServe from like a
store because that's where you bought
the internet back then and I started
using the internet for context I was I
was three years old right then that's
great to hear I was a teenager I was
like 13 or 14 15 maybe okay and I
started using the internet to talk to
people mostly other students in these
forums where we would use our real names
there were no screen names yet or
anything like that
and it was all text-based there were no
pictures on the Internet at that time
like the thought of downloading a
picture it was just like well that's
like two hundred dollars of internet
time to download a single picture so it
was just off the radar I started talking
to this young woman that summer the
really fascinating smart kid about my
age and we continued to talk for off and
on for about three years we talked
sometimes on the phone but usually just
on the Internet and at no point did we
exchange any pictures it was just not it
wasn't even within the culture of the
Internet to exchange pictures and when
we finally met in gosh I guess it was
October of 1996 I had never seen her
before
when I drove across the country to
Maryland to know my god no I had never
seen a single picture of her and I drove
across the country to meet her and I
mean it was truly love at first sight
and we dated very very happily for many
years and we had a wonderful
relationship despite having never seen
pictures of each other when we met three
years after we started talking Wow
that's insane I know isn't that weird
yeah it didn't seem weird at the time
well in hindsight I'm like girl you're
getting catfished as somebody who has
hosted an episode of catfish this is not
looking good for you I'm like waiting
for you to show up and it's like me or
like an old no no no no wow no no she
was lovely she's doing great too I dated
it didn't work out obviously I dated
when I was maybe in middle stall in a
video game I used to play and we used to
hunt together it was like an MMORPG and
we would go like hunting we would be on
the same like video game schedule like
playing we even in the game we got
married and I never saw what she looked
like I like had a crush on her
I guess just like the concept of her
personality all right time we've got a
question that comes from a Liana and I
apologize Aliana if I am mispronouncing
your name although in the context of
your question it's sort of appropriate
for me to mispronounce your name she
writes dear Hank and John I'm currently
a Probie in my new job which means I
have to learn everyone's names this
gives me anxiety since I'm not good at
remembering names and I don't want to
offend anybody by getting their names
wrong do you have any advice on how I
can easily remember the names of my new
coworkers thank you in advance oh my god
this is me this is like I would love any
advice I am so bad at names even if I
you know even if I'm positive about
somebody's name
I am so insecure about it that I don't
trust my own gut 100% I have a friend a
legitimate friend and I know I know I
know that his name is David but when the
time comes to pull the trigger like
never do it are we the same human
because there's just a little part of me
that's like is it David or could it be
Davis on every red carpet I think I know
who a celebrity is and as they approach
I'm like hey girl well cuz it's so risky
I mean hitting the wrong name is such an
epic disaster and just saying hello is
such a relatively small thing and but if
you say the wrong name of a celebrity
first off Tyler I mean you and I are
both let's face it
c-listers I'll take it I'll take it I
would be delighted to be a c-lister and
so you know from experience that when
someone calls you by the wrong name it
does rather set the conversation off on
the wrong foot well I don't well not for
me I think there is a I am very eager to
forgive based on how they go about the
situation like if they are genuinely
embarrassed that I'm like it is
literally no problem my biggest fear is
always when I'm meeting somebody and I
say it's nice to meet you and they said
oh we've met before I'm like yeah I
think that said that's why I never I but
I never correct someone if I know I've
met them before I never want to make
that correction because right what's it
gonna do other than make them feel
terrible right I am right exactly so as
far as trying to remember somebody's
name to answer the question remember and
um what's that movie House Bunny or
something with Anna we can't remember
the name of it I think it's what movie
House Bunny I think with Anna Faris
listen there's a character Anna Faris is
meeting these new people and to remember
all their names they say oh hi my name
is Joanne and she says
Joanne it's the most iconic scene from
the movie so maybe that can be a way you
can do it that's a really really good
idea so you just pronounce their names
back to them in a low growl
and denying that in addition to
remembering everyone's names you will
meet fewer and fewer people as your life
goes on I actually have a genuine piece
of advice for this question though what
I do is I ask them how they spell it and
that's how I remember it so I'm like
okay Sarah with an H or without an H and
then I'll always remember it's Sarah
well no H and then when I see them again
I'm like Sarah with no wait no I'm just
so terrible at remembering people's
names I feel awful about it like even
people I really like or I know well I'm
just terrible at it you know what also I
think I wish I were better at yeah um
once you meet them once they tell you
their name repeat it back to them within
that conversation an obscene amount of
times more than seems normal or
necessary and I think you're more likely
to remember it and be and I I do think
you're more likely to remember but I
also think if you do it way more than is
necessary people start to feel weird
they start to be like boy I haven't
heard my name this many times in a long
time I'd rather make them weird make I'd
rather make them feel weird once in that
first conversation then be like hey girl
and then always be like who is that oh I
knew we weren't gonna get through this
episode without a bleep and sure enough
we aren't oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry no that's fine all right Tyler
we've got one more question for you
before I get to the all-important news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon I know that
that's your favorite part of the podcast
well duh okay Taylor this question comes
from Camille who writes Dear John and
Hank does Voldemort use the bathroom oh
yes there you go Tyler though I doesn't
know I don't know books or the movies
I'm sorry
I know whatever okay I get it I get it
everyone judges I'll just ask you a
different question so that people don't
have to judge you for that horror no you
know what they should accept me for who
I am
not everyone read goosebumps not
everyone read the Bible and not
everyone's gonna read your favorite book
and you're gonna deal with that I you
know what I love that answer it's bold
its expressive it's very Tyler Oakley
that said you should really read Harry
Potter
great you should really what read the
Harry Potter or binge you should also
read Tyler Oakley's New York Times
best-selling memoir binge which
genuinely is really great Oh privately
before but it is it's a it's a really
great book and it's got so many
memorable stories in it and it just it
just tells a very true and moving story
but Harry Potter is also excellent okay
well as somebody who read Harry Potter
do you think of all the more peas I've
been out to you Tunisian computer what I
find interesting about the question is
that you know nobody ever uses the
bathroom in any books or movies it's
like this part of life that we have
largely excluded from our art and maybe
with good reason but but yeah I mean
Isis I assume that Voldemort goes to the
bath I don't know I have a full chapter
in my book about about you do matters so
maybe that's you do the only the artist
who was willing to go where JK Rowling
was not I mean I think that's the
difference to ask though if he uses the
bathroom is to ask if he is at his core
human and I think that's a bigger issue
that you have to grapple in this dang
little book or whatever this Harry
Potter is yeah no that's actually a
really good point like ultimately like
going to the bathroom is mostly about
how we assign personhood and how we like
think of like lives for instance we
never think of Stormtroopers going to
the bathroom because I don't think we
really think of the most people but so
the answer to your question is that we
do not know Tyler yeah would you like to
know what happened on Mars this week
usually Hank delivers the news from Mars
but it falls to me this week so can I
tell you what happened on Mars can I
guess what happens please do guess what
happened on Mars so there they are the
Martians and you know what I like to
imagine gay aliens gays in space I feel
like in in the grand scheme of things I
just hope that out there not only do I
am
certain that there's aliens and things
but like there I just want them all to
be gay was that what's going on on Mars
definitely read some fiction that
imagines that world and it's been it's
been fascinating to read the news from
Mars is as follows there was a black
smudge found on Mars which is bad news
because that black smudge was the Mars
Reconnaissance Orbiter that was supposed
to land on Mars but instead appears to
have crashed and turned into a gigantic
black smudge was there anybody on board
as it was it just kind of like a little
machine oh no no no there was no one on
board in fact no one is allowed to go to
Mars until the Year 2028 or later
because Hank and I made a bet that no
humans will get I may I bet him that
humans will not make it to Mars by 2028
and if I win that bet the podcast will
be renamed Dear John and Hank in the
year 2028 so I am putting all of my
resources right now toward keeping
humans and earth only species for at
least the next you know twelve years
well you're gonna have to fight me
because I'm eager to go to space I'm
like you wanna go to space all you want
you just know but like I want to go
everywhere in space do you really do
yeah the amazing space that's what I
want oh no no no I would not go to space
if you paid me all the money in the
world it just sounds terrifying honestly
even if I died in space what a great
last line of my Wikipedia like tell me
it's not you're welcome
it's it is a good last just I was just
he died in space right I was hoping you
were gonna say what happened in Mars was
Joanne the new Lady Gaga album streamed
from Mars cuz it just came out everyone
should buy oh wow that was I mean you
you squeezed in a lady Gaga reference
knowing that we were near the end of the
podcast it would have been easier had I
just gone the route of did you know Lady
Gaga tweeted hashtag Gaga in space 2015
back a couple years ago and so everyone
thought she was going to space but then
all of 2005
past and on the last day of 2015 I
tweeted her I said girl
whatever happened to Gaga in space why
aren't you going so she might be the one
to make you lose your bet she's gonna
hit Mars before 2028 I mean I I would
not at this point in my life
underestimate Lady Gaga she is a
tremendously talented person did I ever
tell you about the time that we sat on
the same bench shut up tell me more
we did okay so Lady Gaga drove I believe
drove the pace car or was involved in
some way in the Indianapolis 500 of
course and I go to the Indianapolis 500
every year because I am you know a good
Indiana boy and so I was sitting on a
bench at the pagoda and I looked over
and there was a beautiful person wearing
a fire suit next to me with like long
flowing hair and I was like that's a
very unusual situation to see a really
beautiful person with wearing a fire
suit but I didn't think much of it
the race was about to start so I was
pretty focused on the race and then I
noticed that this person was wearing
unbelievably just fabulous beautiful
astonishing shoes like amazing high
heels and I was like that's super weird
a fire suit amazing high heels and then
I was like oh that's Lady gaga
wow did it change your life I mean it
was pretty intense I I had to fight the
urge to you know to have a celebrity
encounter I had to fight the urge to be
like can I have a picture or to say hi
or to whatever I just had to I had to be
cool so I was cool and I'm proud of
myself for being cool that's pretty much
my take away Wow
so you didn't tell her you loved art pop
I did not tell me that I left art pop if
I told her anything honestly Tyler if I
had said anything to Lady Gaga it
probably would have been my friend Tyler
is actually and literally your biggest
fan weight literally size marks alright
we're moving on to the news from AFC
Wimbledon Tyler since you may not be
familiar with AFC Wimbledon
they are a football club currently
playing in the third tier of English
football in South London and we sponsor
them
well my are you there actual and literal
biggest thing might be their biggest fan
for context on the back of AFC Wimbledon
shorts it says dftba nerdfighteria and
also the North Stand of their stadium is
named the John Green stand so it sounds
like they're your biggest fan no no I
paid for that privilege me me forcing
anyone to be a fan of me just exactly
I'm just I'm just making them love me
okay so AFC Wimbledon this is their
first season in a league won they were
not expected to do well and in fact like
most most people thought that they would
likely be relegated at the end of the
season back to League Two where they've
been for the last several seasons but
instead AFC Wimbledon has gone on this
insane winning streak last week they
beat Peterborough one nil a goal from
John Meads and suddenly they are in
sixth place in the table out of twenty
four teams they are in sixth place which
is also the last playoff spot so if the
season were to end today which it won't
because there's still mmm you know like
31 games to play they would finish in
the playoffs there's a long long way to
go but that is very exciting and nobody
could have predicted this level of
success so I am stoked you know I kind
of saw it coming
I saw it within them so when you say
nobody could have predicted it's kind of
an insult to my you know I'm sorry I
appreciate the faith that you have at
ASU in builded at the start of every
season I say that all I want in the
world is for them to finish 19th in
their league whatever that league is so
that they don't get relegated to the
league below but but yeah you're right
you have faith in AFC Wimbledon that I
don't have and that that's probably what
makes you in the end the bigger fan oh
man I'm so excited for AFC Wimbledon Oh
Tyler it's like it's just ah I mean it's
just I almost I can't even explain it
words how cool this is so that is the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon I
apologize for geeking out I'm just
really really excited I'm not gonna lie
about it I'm not gonna hide my
enthusiasm this is who I am
AFC wiggle did are nestled near the top
of the table right between Bristol
Rovers in Port Vale and I am psyched
listen I get it
this is exactly how I feel when a carly
Rae Jepson single is climbing the charts
it's like it's the same emotion oh
that's awesome
Tyler thank you so much for potting with
me today I really appreciate it it was
so much fun this podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins rosianna halse rojas
helps us out with questions Victoria
Bongiorno does social media and many
other things our theme music is by the
brilliant and amazing youtuber
gunnarolla look him up on YouTube Tyler
thank you again and thanks to everyone
for listening oh you can email us at
Hank and John at gmail.com and you can
also follow Tyler on various social
media aren't you mostly just Tyler
Oakley I am Tyler Oakley anywhere you
can search you may find me alright most
I like to follow Tyler on the following
social media accounts YouTube and
Twitter because those are the only two
that I use but I know that he uses other
you know what John I will say you once
years and years and years and years ago
tweeted me I love following you on
Twitter because I feel like more than
anyone else I get a glimpse into your
life and I have always remembered that
I'm like that is the sweetest tweet
anybody's ever sent me well thank you I
do feel that way
and I have to say that it has been an
immense joy in my life to watch the
relationship that you've had with your
audience grow and grow over the years
and I've been a fan of yours since you
had you know subscriber numbers in the
hundreds and it is just such a pleasure
to watch all the all the awesome stuff
that you do and I feel so grateful that
you're in our community shut up likewise
I guess alright well thanks again for
parting with me thanks to everyone for
listening and as we say in my hometown
don't forget to be awesome bye everyone
love you